you want to get started
yeah i mean i'll be very quick my well
now i have no idea if i'm in the camera
or not
no
okay yeah thank you for coming here if
you fail thank you for waking up early
there in berkeley very happy to kick
start day four of our workshop day three
of the mirror workshop here
and we're starting i'm very excited
about this this first talk we're
starting with the survey on average case
hardness improved complexity by susannah
who's coming to us from the czech
academy of sciences sunday the floor is
all yours oh yeah thanks thanks a lot
for inviting me to this workshop i've
been learning a lot
and
yeah so
um something just that i talked about
average pace for this improved
complexity so this is going to be more
of a survey talk uh and i have to say
it's going to be a very biased survey
talk so
please feel free to let me know if i
left anything out that you should
think should have been in or if i forgot
to cite something
um okay so i decided to start with a
problem which i think you all know very
well which is the plan to click problem
so yeah we have two distributions just a
random graph
and the other one is a random graph with
a planted clique so click of size k
and well we know that so here i'm using
omega g to denote the size of the
largest click and we know that in a
random graph when we're sampling engines
with probability a half that's going to
be more or less
2 log n
so there's
a brute force algorithm that can prove
that g has no click of size uh larger
than
the click number
and it runs in time and to the quick
number basically so it it looks at every
set of vertices let's say one larger
than the click number and checks whether
that is a click it's it's not so
then in time into the
um
quick number plus one it can check that
that there's no click of
larger size
and
the
well the plan to click problem is is is
does there exist an algorithm that
distinguishes between both distributions
and polynomial time
and this
will depend on what k we choose right
whether we know of such an existence or
not
but we could also ask the question does
there exist an algorithm that proves
that g has no click
for
uh no k click for some value of k so
in polynomial time so we know that for
large enough k
there does exist some of this such
algorithms but what about for some other
smaller k
and these are two very related questions
they're not exactly the same but they're
very related
and it's
um actually many results for planted
clique
they say they're solving fantastic
they're actually uh dealing with this
question of the reputation problem can i
refute the fact that g does not have a
large cliff
and
i think it's
believed that these might have this very
close or the same uh complexity
um
okay so
uh for this talk i'll be focusing on the
the refutation question so we'll only be
looking at here we have random graphs
and we're supposed to prove that they
don't have a very large click
[Music]
so we have this question does there
exist an algorithm that proves that
there's no k click in polynomial time
and then
another question which
perhaps comes prior to this is does
there exist a proof in polynomial size
there is no proof of polynomial size
there can't be an algorithm that proves
it in polynomial time
so this is precisely improved complexity
what we're
looking for
uh so if we were to think of these um
the values of crate for which we know
there is an
uh
algorithm that actually can't find uh
clicks we know that for larger large
enough okay this is
uh easy
for
too small value of k it's impossible
um and somewhere in the middle it's
believed to be
well perhaps it's algorithmically hard
we don't know any
any uh algorithm
and we could also think of the
proof complexity threshold
so definitely if it's if it's
algorithmically easy it's also provably
easy but then it might be the case that
there's actually a threshold in between
um
we this is something we don't know it
could also be that it just coincides
with with the algorithmic threshold
and just
perhaps an example to show for how
perhaps proofs could be
um so this is
not a true example but let me try to see
if i can um at least pretend
so
uh suppose i want to prove that this
this grass does not have a
uh four click
so
i could present you with the three
coloring of the graph
so that's a
proof and it's a very short proof that
it doesn't have a forklift
um
but three colorings are hard to find so
maybe algorithmically this would be a
hard proof to find but actually the
proof itself is is small
so
the reason this
might have noticed the reason this is
not a an example of
of a separation between these
algorithmic and the proof problem is
that we can just compute the theta
function which is in between the
coloring and the click number and
um
and this will already give me a proof
that there is no
click of size for
so so algorithmically if the graph is
recolorable i can algorithmically prove
that there's no click of size full
okay
are there any questions
okay
so
um
for now i'm gonna uh
well mostly focus on what happens if you
just choose k to be one larger than the
click number of the graph okay so this
would be like down here can we show that
it's
it's hard very close to the impossible
uh threshold
okay and the results will mostly work
for for larger values of k but
just not to get into the exact
parameters we can just focus on the
hardest possible
case what can we
what can we prove in this scenario
uh right so if there is a three coloring
of the graph there can't be any four
clicks there
there's a uh okay
yeah okay so so that would be a proof
there is no four click but i can also
prove it by
computing the theta uh the lavash theta
function can we prove for the
smaller uh like sizes that it's
impossible
[Music]
is it known that it's probably hard or
nice
for cases
so smaller than uh
oh
i'm saying impossible because there
there is going to be a click of size uh
to log in
so i can't prove that there is no click
of talk to log in that's why i'm saying
impossible yeah
yeah
so the question is just a little bit
above this is it really hard
okay so to formalize this
we can define a formula which is going
to state that
g has okay click so this
you get a graph you get a value k and
then you can write a formula that says
that click has that j has a k click and
then if you prove this formula is
unsatisfiable you're proving the graph
has no cake
so this is the formula
so it has
these variables xvi so the meaning is
that vertex v is the if number of a
click so i ranges from 1 to k
so every vertex has the potential of
being either the first the second or the
ks vertex of the click
and then there are three types of
clauses
so there's one clause that's saying that
uh well
there exists cake with numbers so for
each
value in k it's saying that there is
some vertex that is the if click number
then there are clauses saying that
uh a vertex can only be once in a click
this can't be the if and the
i prime
member of the click
and finally there are causes saying that
if um
we have
two vertices that are not an edge
then
uh
these two vertices cannot be in the
click
so there has to be
an edge between vertices
so the question is can we actually prove
a lower bound in the size of a of a
refutation of this formula
uh or can we show that the brute force
so this is the kind of lower bound we
would like to show showing that the
group for this is actually the optimal
and
and actually we don't have many
candidate graphs for
for proving this like what what would be
a hard graph the only natural kind of
good graphs um
that i know
are just random graphs when you choose p
to be close to the threshold of
of having a kick click so a little bit
below so that there's no quicker
why why p so close to the cable
threshold i mean i mean we
for algorithms we think gn half even is
a hard distribution for k
you know much uh much less than half
right right yes no it could be it could
be
uh not necessarily so close i was just
saying close
because that's the
uh easiest possible
uh lower bound we can prove so so in
this sense of like focusing on
on the the easiest possible case of
proving lower bound so
okay the hardest possible problem what
do we think the hardest possible problem
would be when p is close to the k click
threshold
that makes sense
i want one more question about that um
is there has there been any work on
trying to do this kind of thing for uh
maybe paley grabs or these kind of
number theoretic constructions where
there are some i think even open
questions about what the clique number
is
um
i
the only uh
work i know in that sense is for ramsey
graphs
so there's a
work
on
yeah how hard it is to prove that a
graph is ramsey
but that's the only one i know
and perhaps
the reason yeah
i'm not sure so this the the problem
here is already there's not
um
that much known so i'll
get to what's known so perhaps these
problems might be harder i'm not sure
what you're saying is that the same
thing as kind of the encoding the
statement of ramsay's theorem in uh
a formula and then proofs of that or
something yeah yeah so there's one
result of that
uh
yeah um i'm not sure i think it's only
for
for
tree-like resolution or for a very weak
proof system
one question will someone monitor the
chat or should i open it here
okay
i don't know how to
i can leave it there okay
so
okay so
um
another question is what are other
candidate card formulas
so
we uh we saw that the
click formula is a candidate hard
formula when you have a random graph
and so another very natural
uh average average case part formula
would be random k sets and here
yeah there are
different ways of defining
uh the distribution of how you'll sample
the instance but
it doesn't
um well for our purposes it doesn't
matter too much
um
and an important
uh concept here that's used
when we're talking about um
random
case side well in general when we have
some formula is this clause variable
incidence graphs
so we have on on one side we have the
clauses of the formula on the other side
we have the variables and we add an edge
if the clause contains the variable
and here we don't really care about the
signs like if a variable appears negated
or not that doesn't really matter we
just add an edge
and this is very related to another
formula which is the random x xor so
instead of having a clause we just we
either have
um
a constraint saying that the xor of x y
inside is zero or x y and z
is one
and this is an easy formula uh to refute
because we can do gaussian elimination
and and it's actually easy but it's it's
very related in the sense that uh well
depending exactly how you choose the
distribution these cause variable
incidence graphs will actually uh be the
same or at least they're very related
and of course if we're
working with um with
seeing that formulas we will have to
rewrite this for example this constraint
would become these four clauses so just
some technicality
okay and i'd like to talk about a third
um problem which is the the k coloring
so it's it's quite different from k clip
because it's
np harder ready for k equals three
and uh and you'll see there also the
results known are
also quite different
um
so so here again we have this variable
xbi
which means that vertex v is colored
with the color i
and then you have
clauses saying that every vertex has a
color
every vertex has only one color
and that neighbors don't have the same
color and again our
natural
hard candidates would be
random graphs where we should be close
to the threshold
okay so some reasons for studying
average case uh uh complex
average case hardness improve complexity
so
um
well one reason is that it's proving
actually something stronger right you're
actually proving that almost all graphs
are hard so it's a it's a stronger
statement
but also they're not
if we improve complexity we want uh to
prove lower bounds for different proof
systems and they're actually not so many
uh natural candidates for that
so
uh these random formulas or formulas on
random graphs are are
actually good candidates for proving
lower bounds for stronger proof systems
so many of the lower bounds we know to
pro know how to prove are for easy
uh formulas like pigeonhole principle or
satan or the click-coloring principle
that says that a k-minus one colorful
graph does not contain a k-click so
these are all statements that are
actually have
small proofs and strong enough proof
systems
and so in this talk i'll just focus on
those three uh problems that are hard
because there are also average case
results about easy
problems but i'll just focus on those
three all right
uh and of course uh i think these
formulas um
are interesting on their own so
yeah
the random distribution that you believe
is the hardest for the problem yes yes
exactly
exactly so that can we prove a lower
ground at least for that and then how
far can we
can we push the lower bound for these
things do we know lower balance against
worst kids
we we don't for some weak proof systems
we we might like tree like resolution uh
but uh for for others we don't have good
candidates for proving these these
worst-case lower bounds
doesn't have to do with just saying the
problem is not in co-np or
it's not related
worst case i'm saying something about
cohen yeah so if you could prove that
that worst case uh a worst case lower
bound for all persistence then you would
proving that and be different from co
and p so it's definitely yeah related
yeah but there are there well okay i'll
get back to this to your question soon
okay so i've been talking about proof
systems and so let me at least define
some proof system so you know more
concretely what i'm talking about
um
so these
are some group systems i'll talk about i
won't talk about but that's a very
strong
proof system for which we don't know how
to prove any lower bounds
and and then there are these proof
systems for which we do know how to
prove some some lower bounds and this
arrow means that the the one above is
stronger than the one below so it has
more succinct proofs
and here
uh polynomial calculus
we'll see it's defined over
any field and some squares is stronger
only over the reals
okay so resolution um so
it's a very basic proof system there's
only one rule which is the resolution
rule for the cut rule if you have a
clause c or x and the clause d or not x
you can derive the clause c or d
uh and then using this you want to start
with the your
kcmf formula and derive contradiction
derive the empty clause
so this is an example of a resolution
proof so here for example we resolved
over the x variable and then we get this
clause y is that
you're not saying
and then there's like two measures that
we
care about uh well what we care most
about is the size of the proof
and that's just the number of clauses
and another measure that's important is
the the width
of the proof which is the maximum number
of literals appearing in any cause
and the reason that it's important is
well two reasons one uh there we can
find
if there is a
proof of small width we can actually
find such a proof in time
uh and to the w and to the size of the
small way
so
it's it's kind of like well i'll get to
sum of squares later but also if you
have degree d then you do answer z
and and the other reason is that if you
have a strong enough with lower bounds
if you think of with being like linear
in n then you also get a size lower
bound
and
finally we say that the proof is tree
like if the bag is actually a trace so
for example this would be a treat like
resolution reputation so it's
a weaker proof system
okay then we have um
polynomial calculus and cutting planes
so
the exact details are not very important
for this talk so i'm going to go
a bit uh
fast don't worry if you don't get
exactly the details
but you you transform these these
clauses in the case of polynomial
calculus into some polynomial such that
this polynomial is satisfied if and only
if
uh the clause is satisfied
so here this polynomial is is equal to
zero either if x is
one y is zero or z is one
and then for
um the other
here we're transforming the clause into
an inequality
so we're saying that either
uh so this inequality has to be larger
than one which means that either x is
one y is zero
and then there are some rules so there's
some uh boolean and for uh enforcing
that the variables are zero one
uh you can take linear combination of
polynomials so this is some sound rule
over
uh whatever field you're working in you
can multiply by a variable and the
reputation is if you derive
some contradictory statement 1 equals 0.
and again we have proof size which is
the number of monomials in the proof
when you spend themselves and the proof
degree is the maximum degree of any
polynomial appearing in the proof
and you have squared being bigger than
zero
you have like sum of squares being
bigger than zero in this left-hand side
sum of squares like five polynomials
square that they need to be positive no
no this you don't have here no okay no
so you only have these rules you don't
have some expressions yeah
and here for for cutting planes it's
similar you have these um
constraints on
each variable
you have linear combinations
and and then the special thing is you
have this division rule which only holds
over integer values so this is what
yeah actually
uh allows you to do more than just uh in
your program you're actually working
with integers and yeah the derivation if
you derive my
reputation if you derive minus one is
greater than zero
and here the proof size the number of
inequalities in the proof and we don't
have an uh something analogous to degree
here because everything are just
linear inequalities so
okay and finally sum of squares which
probably
um
know
very well so um
so some of squares can be also viewed as
as a proof system
um so again here you translate the club
the clauses you can there's these two
ways of translating them
uh and now suppose you have
a set of polynomials so here p one
through p m
uh
and you have another set q one to ql
and these are polynomials which are
greater than zero and the ps are equal
to zero
so a sum of squares reputation of
this set of polynomials would be
these rs sets
such that
uh if
this the sum is equal
uh to minus one and each of the s i's is
actually a sum of squares
so the reason this is a refutation so
let's see uh if if there were
um a satisfying assignment for these
polynomials
then if i were to plug
the satisfying assignments in here
uh all these piece i's would evaluate to
zero so this would evaluate to zero no
matter what the r's are
the all the q i's would be positive
or non-negative
and and the s i's are non-negative
because they're a sum of squares so this
would have to be
non-negative and so if it's equal to
minus one you're refuting the set of
polynomials
and then again you have definition of
size and degree
here
so now let's see what are the results
known for
these uh
systems so
here i have um the last tree-like
resolution resolution polynomial
calculus sum of squares and cutting
points
and the problems we're considering i
added three xor uh just to point out
that many of the results for
uh random threesat that we know actually
they're a consequence of the result for
random three x total
so
there's uh hotel uh
semedevi from 88 which proved that
um that well it follows from their proof
that random three xor is is hard
uh the exact parameters were later
improved
and yeah and i also wanted to point out
that it follows from 3xor because this
also says that uh
um
it's
it's falling from an easy problem
actually so if you want to generalize
this stronger proof system something
else has to be done you can't you can't
depend on the hardness of three xor
um
then for polynomial calculus it was
first shown for
um
fields
the characteristic different from two
and
and this is um
also because it was shown for three xor
and three xor is easy if you're over
characteristic too
so so it was uh a bit later on that it
was also shown for for this case
and and then for sum of squares um
it was also shown for for a random 3xor
and these results of these two they
actually boil down to
uh saying that whatever sum of squares
can do is equivalent to
in terms of degree is equivalent to what
resolution can do in terms of width
so it's really just boiling down to
resolution
and then interestingly for cutting
planes um
well three xor is
it's a very recent result that it's
closely polynomially at least possibly
normally easy
[Music]
[Music]
yeah if you allow for
like
log n variables for calls then
then you can get hardness
but otherwise it's open
and then for k coloring there's
much less known so
uh
for resolution
we know that it's hard
um
then for
well for the little calculus here we
only have worst case here we do have
worst case but it's actually a reduction
to pigeonhole principle so it's also
reducing to an easy problem
um
so it's
not
possible to actually generalize this to
for example sum of squares where where
pigeon hope is full disease
and
uh and then for sum of squares um
[Music]
i think there are a couple more results
this was the
strongest one i found which is just from
this year so it's only for the case um
where you have g and a half
and
and and what they show is that you need
large degree so you need degrees larger
than nugget
so it's not a size lower bound in the
sense that we defined earlier but it's
something towards that it's a degree
lower amount
and then for
k-click
well there's i guess even less known so
we know it's
if you want exactly the hardness that we
expect which is end to the k we know
it's hard for tree-like resolution but
then it's
uh
we don't have the same result for any
other proof system there are some
partial results for resolution and
also for sum of squares we also have
degree lower bound for this case when
p is a half
so just to go back to the discussion
about gauge
the cable
oh the the in the k click yeah it's in
the exponent of the lower bounds so hard
means enter the king in this in uh click
that's that's the
um
trivial algorithm runs in time into the
k
right but it doesn't depend anymore
where k is
oh this is so actually
uh this is supposing k is like very
close to
to the click number so it should
actually be under the click number oh
okay um yeah and what's playing the role
of the click number for instance within
the preset or the k
so it's there there isn't an analogous
because it's already for for three sets
or three coloring that's already hard
like for any so for
instance three so there is this alpha
parameter so for any of the number of
clauses
ah right right yes yes exactly there is
this yes there's this parameter so here
it appears as this delta which is you
have m clauses and variables you have
this delta factor
and it does play a role in what lower
bound you can prove yes
but for all there is
um no
i think well for constant deltas yes but
if you choose delta like for resolution
if you think if you choose
delta
square root n
oh wait i think maybe i wrote it wrong
maybe it's delta
yeah
if you choose delta square root n
then then i think it's easy for
uh
resolution if you have uh n to the one
point five
plus epsilon maybe okay
you can see that this won't apply for
that and then there are i think yeah
there are results that it's actually
easy if you have enough another quality
and the other where you don't specify it
it's just that there's
like for the polynomial will help loose
and lower
um i'm not exactly sure
what's how they depend on delta
there's some dependence on delta yes yes
and definitely like for cake coloring
there's also uh dependence on
on the probability of choosing an edge
so
these are all like these are all for
size unless you said degree right
they're all for size unless it says
degree exactly so
actually but but the okay this is just
some ignorance so how do you get from
degree to size for
i guess for for for resolution and for
sos these are all coming from with their
degree lower bounds right and i guess do
you get to size just by saying that the
degree the width or degree is extremely
high and therefore it implies a size
lower bound
for for a random three set yes
um and even this k coloring result also
is is this a very large width
uh
i'm not mistaken
uh and for tree and for tree like like
the like resolution heart the clique
thing is not coming from with that's
like
really going straight to size somehow
this is not going through it no it's
because there is actually a with k proof
so
um
yeah just going through with you
wouldn't be able to get
into the k
so something i find interesting about
the k-click problem is that it really
forces you to go beyond
just uh proving with lower bounds you
have to really understand
um
come up with the other techniques for
improving size lower bounds
where does the where does the rossman
well i guess the rossman the rossmann
result for click is for circuits
yeah yeah
okay thanks
how do you go from which to size oh this
is the word
this is uh a result of uh
justin from 2001
and it's it's it's not it's very neat uh
it's showing that if you uh if you have
us
if you have a small with proof you can
actually transform it into a small size
group or the other way around
uh
whichever no the other way if you have a
small size proof
uh you can transform it into a small
width group
um and you can do this
uh
in in some sense for tree-like
resolution it's very
very like tight for resolution it only
works
uh you don't get such a small width but
you get smallish width
so so yeah
this is
and this is often used in proquebex to
prove lower bounds and you also have the
same thing for polynomial calculus and
sum of squares that if you have a
large enough degree if it requires
linear degree you automatically get a
size lower bound because of a really and
then the proof is a bit more complicated
from how you get that
but if there's a linear size
lower bound you have a size lower about
an exponential size lower bound
and but it's only strong enough so if
you can prove like a square then
uh
lower bound degree lower bound that
doesn't imply any size lower bounds but
has to be above square root n
um
ten more minutes
okay
okay so i
now plan to talk a bit about um how
these results are proven and
a big part of it is finding structure in
randomness so how does this um why does
randomness imply hardness so you find
some structure
and prove that
uh a
random instance has this structure and
that the destructive hardness
so here's um
an example for k-stats
so
here what
is used for i think all the the lower
bounds that we know is
expansion of the
constrained variable graph so we say a
graph is a s epsilon microtite expander
if
you look at any set uh
u of bertzies as long as that set is not
too big the it has a lot of neighbors
so for example here if i choose this set
u
and i look at the neighbors of the set
it's uh larger than venue
and
this is
interesting because this guarantees that
you can always find a match
between the left side and the right side
so just to get a bit of a feeling of how
you can improve lower bounds at least
for for resolution i wanted to introduce
uh this game which is
um
oh yes here i'm going to use this as an
example so here's a clause
of the
this
constrained variable graph
and and the game has two players it has
prover and delayer
uh the approver is saying that uh the
formula is unsatisfiable
and the layer is saying that uh i know a
satisfying assignment for this
formula
and the delay is lying because the
formula isn't satisfiable
the approver has to actually prove that
he's lying
so
uh the game goes as follows so the
approver can ask
the value of some variable
so for example okay if you know a
satisfying assignment then what is the
variable the value of the variable x
and then the delay will answer something
x equals true
uh and then they'll write it down
on the role
the layer answered x equals true
and then the approval might ask some
other variable what about said
and the layer will answer something that
equals false so they write that down
and then the prover asks what about w
and then the layer
if the delay were to answer w equals
false
then uh this assignment x equals true z
equals false of w equals false would
falsify this some cause of the formula
so then prover would win and the game
would be over because she actually
proved that uh the delayer's assignment
is not uh satisfying all causes of the
formula
so
uh delair is smart so he's actually
gonna enter w equals true
okay so the game has to continue they
write w equals true
and then another thing that the prover
can also do is maybe there are some
questions that were asked that she
thinks are not needed anymore so she can
just forget
some just erase
something in the record
and
uh this is in order to save space
because we'll say that the delayer wins
the r gain on the formula
if
uh if we have a scroll with only our
lines
and
prover cannot
exhibit a falsified clause
so there's no strategy for prover that
can actually catch the layer
of falsifying the clause
uh and okay i didn't mention but if uh
if the approver erases something uh then
and asks that again the delayer can
answer something else it doesn't have to
be consistent with previous answers
because there's no record of it
so
so
this game is used uh to prove uh with
lower bounds so if if the delayer wins
the r game on f then resolution requires
with r to refute up
okay
uh and then we can actually use
extension
uh yeah what does it mean
winning we are game
it means regardless of the question
regardless of how prover the questions
the order the strategy the prover has uh
if there are only our lines here in the
scroll then uh the approver cannot catch
the
uh contradiction and what the layer is
saying and the answer is
forever
so
yeah so for um random
random case tasks
the the expansion is what's going to
help delay or be able to
always find
some variable to satisfy the clause
uh no matter what as long as there's
as long as the number of uh questions is
small
that will
correspond to a small set of constraints
that are being
that contain that variable and therefore
it's possible for the
delayer to always
keep
consistent
uh locally consistent
so the lower bound actually yeah boils
out to proving two lemmas that if
this constraint variable graph is an
expander the layer will win for
um some r
uh which is
going to be
yeah related to this uh
s of the expansion
and then the other part is saying that
well if we have a random graph it's a
good expansion this is very very easy
to prove
okay so this is just a bit of a flavor
of how these lower bounds
can be proven
and then for
uh coloring
uh
it's actually a another
um
structure
that is found
so um
yeah so here so we have this graph g
which we're trying to prove is not k
colorable
and
s
is the maximum number such that
any uh
subgraph of g with s vertices is k
colorable so here's an example
so here i have this this graph and it's
it's not uh three colorable
well
you have to put some color in the middle
so suppose you put blue and then
going around it you'll see that you have
to alternate between two colors and it's
an odd cycle so
it's not three colorable
uh
but if you remove any vertex of this
graph then you have a three colorable
graph
so here the s value would be five
because any
uh subgraph of five vertices is three
colorable
okay this is the s parameter
and then there's this
beta parameter which is simply you look
at the sub graph and it's the number of
uh vertices with degree between one and
k minus one
okay so for example here in this
subgraph uh it's these are induced
subgraphs you have uh beta equals five
for this one you have beta equals two
because
uh you're
you want a degree between one and two
you only have
two birds
and then there's this
well kind of magic uh
uh definition of uh subcritical k
expansion so it's a bit hard to parse so
let me just explain with an example
so here okay you're going to take the
maximum that uh over some values of t so
let's start fixing with the t equals
five
and
and then we look at uh subgraphs of
g which are connected and have less than
five parentheses but more than three
vertices
so these two are examples and then i can
also take subgraphs
uh so these are the only two
um connect its subgraphs
up to isomorphism
and then here these are the also
connected subgraphs
and i can find the beta value of all of
these and the smallest one is two
so for t equals five i'll have this is
the smallest theta number
and then
also for
uh we'll do this for
t equals four which we have the same
subgraph except have an extra one and
again we'll get
uh beta equals two
and do this up to t equals two and this
will be actually the for all of them
there will be one case with theta equals
two so this will be the value of the
subcritical expansion in this example
um
and then again the lower bound follows
from
uh these two lemmas so uh the resolution
width of repeating this
this
formula
is
larger than this expansion value so
that's one
one lemma and then showing that if you
choose a
random graph it's going to be it's good
to have large
um sub-critical k expansion
it's the same same kind of uh strategy
for
for coloring except a more complicated
version of of expansion
okay
and then
um some
more details on
some of the things that are known for
click
so again here we're choosing uh
p close to the k click threshold so this
is like the hardest possible scenario
uh
so there is
some kind of lower bound for
which holds for resolution for very
dense graphs
um so delta is the average degree so the
average degree has to be
uh almost n and minus
some ends of the epsilon
and
and
and also you need large k
but in at least in some setting you get
some
some lower bounds and it's not of the
type and to the k but it's
some
um
lower bound for this random setting
then also you have some almost 2 to the
k lower bound for resolution when when k
is
small
uh and then you have this end to the k
lower bound so that like exact right um
lower bound for tree-like resolution
also for
another restriction which i didn't talk
about uh restriction of resolution which
is regular resolution um
so there you can also get this enter the
k lower bound
and
then yes for sum of squares you can get
this login degree lower bounds when you
choose
uh probability a half
and it's
as
we saw before so it's open to actually
prove this n to the k size lower bound
for uh resolution polynomial calculus or
sum of squares uh this is yeah something
we don't know
how to do
so
perhaps i'll just show
this
uh
one of the properties that's used for
proving uh
click lower bounds which is
it's it's actually very simple so
uh here this m hat is actually the set
of common neighbors of uh of a set of
vertices so for example here if we have
the set uh u of vertices
the these uh all of these uh green
vertices they are neighbors of both
vertices and you
okay so these are like the yeah the
common neighbors
and the property here that's used is
that uh any
r click as long as r is not too large
can be extended
in many ways
okay so so if we choose a a u
subset of u which is not too large it
has many common neighbors
so this property is enough to prove uh
tree-like resolution lower bounds
um
so again you have these two
two
lemmas and
but it's
it's not enough to prove lower bounds
for stronger proof systems
and so
yeah can show
um why
so a k minus one completes uh
by uh complete type graph
it's
uh
it's easy to say it doesn't it to see it
doesn't contain the k click and yes it
does satisfy this property
um because if i choose any
any small enough few it will have many
even more than the random graph uh
common neighbors
so
so this property is not enough
okay i'm going to skip
some other um properties which is used
for proving
um
lower bounds for
stronger
for regular resolution
and
um
and this other property is it's
interesting in the sense that uh it's
not satisfied by the k minus one
part-time graph so it's a potential of
actually
um being
a property that can be used to prove
stronger lower bounds
okay okay so just yeah uh so wrapping up
so we saw yeah average case proof
complexity of these three anti-hard
problems uh
we're uh usually interested in the size
of the proof so the width or degree
lower bounds are also interesting
and these
um
proof lower bounds and pi lower bounds
for algorithms
um yeah i didn't say like for resolution
lower bounds and five
lower bounds for stat solvers that are
based on resolution
these are good candidate hard instances
for strong proof systems and
we don't have so many good candidates so
they're interesting to study and the
lower bounds uh often they boil down to
identifying some structure and
randomness that can be used to prove
these lower bounds
and there are many open problems
you don't know how to solve so yeah
that's it thanks
super interesting talk are there any
questions either here in berkeley or
over zoom
uh yeah thanks for the talk very
interesting um i wanted to ask so we
heard in one of the previous talks about
this possibility that maybe uh so
specifically in that case low degree
algorithms are equivalent to uh sum of
squares so kind of translating that to
this context is there any possibility
that even though these have some strict
orderings kind of in general in the
worst case these proof systems
uh that for some large class may be of
random problems uh some of them might be
equivalent uh maybe for example one kind
of natural possibility would be
polynomial calculus and sum of squares
which are already kind of similar
that they would be equivalent for uh
let's say uh random k-sat or
something right or for you know natural
distributions over let's say maybe some
class of csps or
something like that
um
i think there's definitely that that
possibility i i don't
know how to distinguish that from uh
yeah if these problems are hard for both
proof systems then i guess the proof
systems
would be performing equally badly on
both of them
um
so
i think this is
for several of these hard problems this
is believed to be the case
so this something would be equivalent
yes in the in this average case scenario
for
heart problems
um there are there are some
results too
um
yeah i i won't remember right now but i
think there are also other results of
classes of uh
problems that are actually equivalent
between
proof systems
so
yeah definitely
and so relatedly actually i mean we
expect this entire picture to be
read right when the story is over except
for these easy squares on the for a 3x
or yes exactly okay okay
any more questions
yeah we have one more over here
[Music]
you had a potential region where
where clique is
as algorithmically hard but is easy to
prove
i guess is is is that
uh
are there any no known instances in that
region
i no i don't think so
i i don't know of any and i and i don't
think there's
there's anything known so i think it's a
it's an interesting problem
yeah
i wanted to ask a similar question
with more freedom if is there any
natural problem that's the case where
it's hard to find a proof but there are
short proofs that are hard to find yes
yes uh there's um
so there's a
recent uh result showing that
uh resolution is not automatable so what
it means is that there are problems
which have short resolution proofs but
these proofs cannot be found in
polynomial time msp equals np
so this this is definitely the case so
um are these natural problems or they're
constructed for i mean okay it's not a
real definition naturally yeah but they
they are they are cons so the problem uh
is actually saying that
uh some formula has
a small resolution refutation so you can
encode this as a cnn formula it says
that some formula has a small resolution
reputation
and
uh and in some cases there will be a
a small refutation of this but
finding it uh will
okay so whenever the formula is
satisfiable there will be a small
refutation of this but finding it would
imply that you found the satisfying
assignment
so and this is this uh is hard
so it's yeah it's it's kind of made for
for this so
um
yeah i don't know about other
combinatorial formulas where
where this is the case
also it's it's it's uh it's sort of
rumored to happen actually also for
simple things like random
random three sets like there's um
wait is it random three set which yeah
it's that right like uh fight so there's
this end of the 1.5
clause density thing for refuting
threesat uh
you know with some squares or spectral
methods or whatever but then there's
this work by figa kim and ofek which
says that if you have only end to the
1.4 random clauses there is a short
refutation we just don't think you can
find that refutation efficiently right
that's a good example yeah yeah that's a
very good example yeah that's a more
natural
i see yeah
i mean but that's you know you're not
getting like worst case complexity
theoretic evidence they're like we as
far as we know there could be an
algorithm at end of the one before we
don't have you know complexity
reductions to rule that out but it's
like uh
it's a potentially different different
kind of example right yeah yeah let's
see but so when we do these quiet
plantings to try to argue in a much
weaker sense that things are hard to
refute uh
they could very well be a short proof
that doesn't
yeah yeah
yeah there could there could be but for
example the sum of squares one they're
actually ruling out small degree proofs
it's not only algorithmically so
sometimes the way you prove the
algorithmic results is actually uh proof
floor bounds
but you could potentially only prove an
algorithmically algorithmical
i see interesting
okay any more questions
no it's not listening suzanne again
thank you